looking for a new car yeah but you're
not finding anything right and my budget
no will show us the car you want there
it is
okay now search for it again but in
green green yeah why would I do that
just go ahead wow it's so much cheaper
and that's our business model here at
green cars dot get all the cars you like
putting green forests kelly green pea
green olive char true okay that's enough
anything else besides green cars nope
like I just said all our cars are green
cars I just don't really like the color
green that much yeah I know no one does
that's the point you like the price
though right yeah I do and you don't
like this price correct no it's too much
so then buy the green car ass take it
easy alright sorry I snapped at you are
you embarrassed to drive a green car
yeah kind of well don't worry about it
prior to every green car delivery we'll
send you a plain envelope in it you'll
find a wig a hat glasses and a fake
beard so no one will know who's driving
that green car
Wow this isn't a bad deal at all hey
Janine I don't know you that's my mom
Green bars dump is the color you need at
the price you left
[Applause]